so this is kyle coming at you guys from
bricktown new jersey
clearly driving to a proud boys got a
debate club for y'all
this suits big brown a little bit more
than theo because
that dirty south you feel me man baby
kevin costner hitters dances with wolves
or yellowstone let me know what you all
think
love you guys gang gang
dutton dudes oh
i loved it have you seen yellowstone i
have not yet so you're out
[Laughter]
hey anyone else watched it though y'all
some
hoes no one's seen yellowstone theo
definitely hadn't seen it nope i saw
trailers
i didn't i haven't seen yellowstone but
i did i obviously have
uh subscribed to their merch drop
and actually this shirt came with a real
fake gold nugget in the pocket
ooh maybe a little arrowhead in the
pocket
is it who's birthday birthday
birthday birthday uh listen dancing with
the wolves was cool but
yellowstone's origin now that [ __ ] is
dope three seasons of
filming season four now it's so good the
dances of wolves is
original too man yeah no
brendan it is okay obviously
i have a family member who is part
native american pigeon indian
oh okay and a pigeon indian i've never
heard of that
yeah pull it up nick pull up the pigeon
pigeon indian does that just mean a
white person no hill people they call
them hill they
some no hill people are west virginia
doug
yeah well whatever man
no domestic pigeon that's an animal bro
pigeon indian yeah pigeon india man
brief
very brief tribe
yeah anyway they had a couple year run
but they didn't listen uh
i feel like this is a standard that's
been wiped from the internet yeah
[Laughter]
i'm just saying i got about probably 15
pigeon in me you know
uh like if you throw a bunch of seed
around me on the ground i [ __ ] lose
my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's like catnip for you theo yeah right
man
i'll be there all afternoon you'll keep
me busy if i was a security guard you
could rob my bank dude with just a
handful of seed
it's like skateport skateboards for a
chappelle he was nuts
i go crazy yeah yeah i can't handle it
um but anyway dances with wolves man uh
i i remember the film pretty well and we
actually did a reenactment of it there's
a couple scenes during uh
church camp once but
they had um if you ever
we used to play charades a lot of times
i feel like we're at theo's funeral and
he's talking to us
about the good days he recorded a
message for everybody
he's just firing shots off at people his
final message
this final message would be about indian
pigeons right
this is like michael jordan's hall of
fame induction speech
look out first i want to thank everybody
for coming today
and i know half of you guys probably
drove a long way to be
here or uber hopefully we sold tickets
or ubered make sure you get your merch
in the back everybody
theo rip merch
that's gonna be a hot seller
yeah get that grape gang shirt on the
way out
game we even got bobble tears in the
back for the vips
dude get that bottle service baby
speaking of uh vips uh oh did you have
some
no i got nothing else man but that fella
what was he asking about oh
dancing with wolves that i love and i
love doing dancing with wolves because
it's a good learners prac it's a good
learners thing
for charades if you're doing charades
with a child and they don't know how to
do it and you're trying to explain
it and they just keep kind of beating
their head against the desk or just
sucking on a [ __ ] marker
okay you give them dances or wolves and
it's easy to figure out dances
with yeah y'all some hoes because you
can't
listen the dutton ranch yellow stone rip
wheeler bath that [ __ ] is
fire until you've seen it y'all can't
jump in this column well you got to
start with dances with wolves first dude
that came out in the early 90s
you got to start with that if you
haven't started with that then you can't
watch yellowstone
they have nothing to do with each other
you know i mean it's modern you know it
moves into the modern world
you got to peep it man yeah but look if
you want to do all the indians have
iphones and all that [ __ ] then go on
brendan okay
but i'm talking old school man i mean i
just think it's easy to help a kid learn
charades dancing at wolves it's a good
thing to learn charades by
whereas yellowstone it's kind of hard to
do yellowstone how do you do that
so based on which one is easier to do
charades
i'm going with dancing that's fair
[Music]
is